let's face it there aren't that many new
releases out right now but if you're
looking for a big old open world to get
lost in for a few dozen hours then there
are plenty out there to choose from
here's our selection of the 20 best open
world games to play right now make sure
to like this video and subscribe for
more
red dead redemption 2 arrived about 8
years after the original and rockstar
games didn't just deliver another red
dead redemption with the prequel they
offered an unparalleled western filled
with shootouts chases armed robbery and
general drunken debauchery alongside a
plethora of other activities
its take on the dying age of the outlaw
emphasizes exploration rather than just
telling you where to go leading to lots
of fun anecdotes as you venture into the
wilderness to hunt a rare animal or take
back a bounty target
it's a video game unicorn we're unlikely
to ever see again selling over 150
million units across two console
generations and it'll soon be coming to
a third grand theft auto 5 delivers a
bright vibrant satirical los angeles
dubbed los santos and lets you use it as
your playground
even if you never want to play through
the main story you can sync dozens or
even hundreds of hours into gta 5 just
by exploring the city causing chaos and
of course making bank
or you could just play tennis and once
you've had your fill of offline play gta
online provides an always evolving place
to take over los santos with your
friends even eight years after it
launched
the open world game that would define
open world games for years to come as in
it's still doing it the legend of zelda
breath of the wild doesn't have no in
its vocabulary in a radical departure
from the other games in the series
breath of the wild ditches traditional
dungeons and progression in favor of a
truly free-form structure that lets you
take on the final boss 20 minutes in if
you want to getting there and fighting
shape is quite a bit harder but the
steps you take to get there are up to
you even if that means solving a puzzle
in a way the designers didn't intend or
leaping over the entirety of a castle to
skip straight to the final boss
no not the version of no man's sky that
released back in 2016. that game was
suffering from an identity crisis and
was undercooked in several key areas but
developer hello games has drastically
improved the space exploration game
since then the open world is so big that
it's not feasible to see the whole thing
letting you stop suffering from
completionist stress and actually enjoy
the unique animals and flora you find
with base building multiplayer and a
steady stream of updates adding more to
do and see no man's sky is a remarkable
turnaround for a game that could very
well have been on a biggest
disappointments list before
rocksteady set a new standard for
superhero games with batman arkham
asylum and the studio somehow surpassed
it with its sequel batman arkham city
the open world caped crusader game
features an oft copied mixture of 3d
brawling action and stealth along with
incredibly fun traversal via batman's
cape and various gadgets there are tons
of collectibles and side missions to
find and complete as you'd expect given
batman's many enemies and getting from
point a to point b is just as
entertaining as whatever it is batman
actually has to do when he gets there
when a game is available on everything
from xbox 360 to amazon echo devices you
know it's doing something right the
elder scrolls 5 skyrim didn't need to
revolutionize the formula bethesda game
studios established in its previous
games but it did refine it with an
emphasis on discovery and freedom as
well as a gorgeous and varied open world
heading off in a random direction in
other games usually just leads to a lot
of wasted time in skyrim however it may
lead to a new dungeon to explore a new
city to enter or a new dangerous dragon
to slay no two players experience are
ever exactly the same and with a
classless leveling system that lets you
customize your character exactly how you
see fit you can keep experimenting and
finding new things to do for years
one problem with big open world games
can be inconsistency in writing quality
the smaller side quests can sometimes
have a this is filler content feel to
them but that is not the case with the
witcher 3 wild hunt cd projekt red's
enormous open world is host to a ton of
different missions ranging from slaying
powerful monsters to helping an old lady
locate a lost cast iron pan and despite
the superficial premise of some of these
they're all given the same care and
attention which only helps to further
immerse you into the world and geralt's
complicated role within it
arguably the greatest game in the
assassin's creed series may only be
tangentially related to the assassins vs
templar storyline but that also means
it's much less tied down by its baggage
a caribbean pirate adventure with a
heavy focus on sea exploration via ship
and tracking down buried treasure
assassin's creed iv black flag is a
tremendous adventure with a world you'll
actually want to explore rather than
just head to the next waypoint on your
map tracking down a powerful enemy ship
and tearing it to shreds with your
cannons before moving in to take out the
captain is a rush every time as is
trying to take on a well-defended
fortress while avoiding a barrage of
incoming shrapnel and explosives it's
the perfect game for those who haven't
been drawn to other assassin's creed
games as it wastes no time throwing you
into the action
one of the biggest games of all time at
this point minecraft's open world is
unlike most of the games on our list
because it's different for every player
several times bigger than the actual
planet earth the world isn't just a huge
part of the game it is the game from
digging underground for rare minerals to
finding the perfect place for your
shelter minecraft's fun is in seeing
what your own unique world has to offer
all while fending off hunger and the
occasional creeper
there hasn't been a more consistent
developer for xbox over the past decade
than playground games with each forza
horizon game topping the previous one
forza horizon 4 takes the open world
racing series to rural england sending
supercars barreling across the rolling
countryside and through tiny villages as
residents just try to enjoy their
morning tea as with the other horizon
games it's a perfect choice for those
who usually don't enjoy racing because
of its excellent rewind system as well
as tons of stunts and non-race events to
try out forza horizon 4 also added a
season system changing areas and even
making some of them accessible such as
frozen lakes during the winter
it's a series that's been around for
decades but the 2020 iteration of
microsoft flight simulator is on another
level exploring the entire world in your
airplane with many of the airports and
buildings being bespoke rather than data
generated is an experience you simply
cannot get in another game it truly is
an open world as checking out your ideal
tourist destination is as simple as
setting coordinates and heading in that
direction it's a relaxing and
refreshingly goal-free game that's
perfect if you're looking for something
to just unwind with in the evenings even
if you have no interest in ever actually
flying a plane or traveling the globe
ubisoft knocked it out of the park with
far cry 3 sending a group of privileged
students into a gorgeous tropical
setting filled with dangerous enemies to
hunt outposts to capture and towers to
climb yes the towers from so many
ubisoft games made an appearance here
but they functioned more as mini puzzles
than simple busy work the chaos you can
cause in far cry 3 is nearly
unparalleled whether it's by speeding
into a group of enemies and firing an
explosive at them or luring wildlife out
of the woods to attack your targets
the story might be unfinished but there
is no denying that metal gear solid 5 is
one of the most immersive and compelling
open world games of all time it's
actually a few different open worlds
with one in afghanistan and one in
angola and each is yours to explore
aside from completing main objectives
venom snake can sneak into various areas
to scout for information learn
interesting details on the enemies he
encounters via his reconnaissance
technology and use a fulton recovery
system to send supplies and people back
to mother base metal gear solid 5's
biggest surprise is that it delivered
near perfect open world stealth gameplay
from a series that often prioritized
story above all else
turning a long-running open world series
known for goofy brawling combat into a
role-playing game sounded like a very
weird decision but very weird is part of
the yakuza game's dna with the seventh
main entry yakuza like a dragon sega
made the radical decision to shift to
role-playing combat similar to games
like dragon quest in order to fit the
protagonist ichiban kasiga's obsessive
otaku interests but this shift a
surprisingly welcome one doesn't stop
like a dragon from continuing the series
famous
eccentricities all the weird open-world
stuff you expect to see in yakuza
remains in like a dragon including
plenty of optional mini-games and some
truly incredible sub-stories
while the legend of zelda breath of the
wild revolutionized open world design
when it launched in 2017 another game
horizon zero dawn took more of an if it
ain't broke don't fix it approach and it
saw nearly as much acclaim as zelda set
in a post-apocalyptic north america
that's been overtaken by dinosaur-like
robots horizon features some of the
familiar tropes of other open world
games including unlocking areas via
towers but it's paced so well and there
is so little filler to get through that
the familiarity doesn't feel like
uninspired design tremendous combat and
the ability to ride on the back of a
robot dinosaur as you plan your next
move help to make it a thrill until the
closing credits
monolith's middle earth shadow of mordor
and its sequel shadow of war clearly got
inspiration from the assassin's creed
and batman arkham games when crafting
its dark tolkien world but the studio
didn't just make a copycat game shadow
of war in particular makes fantastic use
of the nemesis system a feature that
lets unique enemies remember past
encounters and evolve based on them
coming back to find you while you're out
exploring and potentially throwing all
your plans into disarray you can also
use this to your advantage in order to
move an enemy further up the food chain
and then mind control them gaining a
tactical advantage among the urix and
orcs
special spectral abilities also let you
move across the vast planes in a flash
often culminating in a brutal takedown
of an unexpecting enemy
one of the biggest games to release on
ps4 and ps5 along with the standalone
adventure miles morales marvel
spider-man is the web slinger's most
impressive outing ever for the first
time since spider-man 2 a few
generations ago it actually feels good
to sort around new york city and save
helpless citizens from nerdy wells and
with a flashy acrobatic combat system
that blends some elements from a
more caped superhero game with the flair
and goofiness we expect from spider-man
collectibles random open-world events
and plenty of unlockable goodies makes
spider-man a ton of fun to play once the
story is finished and it's even more
stunning on the ps5 with its visual
enhancements
already experts in open world design
from their time working on the infamous
series the developers at sucker punch
went in a completely different direction
with ghost of sushima a mostly realistic
take on samurai combat in feudal japan
the game's environments are absolutely
breathtaking with flowing fields of
bright red flowers and trees rustling in
the wind traveling it whether on foot or
horseback is a joy especially when you
come across another samurai who wants to
engage in an all or nothing jewel that
ends in a single sword slash
if ratchet and clank tony hawk and jet
set radio all came together and formed a
delicious cosmic gumbo it would be
sunset overdrive initially an xbox one
exclusive the open world third-person
shooter is incredibly self-aware and
satirical even making use of the game's
ui for jokes and it plays fast and loose
with the laws of physics to great effect
surfaces are bouncier than trampolines
and you can grind on edges and rails at
will all while blasting mutated energy
drink creatures with ridiculous weapons
in fact moving constantly actually
increases your score and sunset city is
a blast to navigate
hideo kojima managed to get two
different games on this list and they
couldn't be more different after parting
ways with metal gear solid publisher
konami the director relaunched kojima
productions and created death stranding
a game focused on creating connections
literal and figurative between people at
a time when society is just short of
collapse this mostly involves delivering
packages as you climb drive and hike
across the wasteland and work to avoid
mysterious creatures and other dangerous
scavengers and while that may not seem
like video game material the gorgeous
tranquil environments and breathtaking
music and sound design makes such a
simple task feel monumental by creating
your own bridges you can even make the
journey back easier and maybe even help
out another player or two
so there you have it 20 open world games
to play right now if you're looking to
lose yourself in a virtual world for
more lists like this make sure to like
this video and subscribe to gamespot you
can find me on twitter at lucy james
games and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you